on a une écologie politique dans ce pays
mais qui pour être un peu taquin est une
écologie pastèque g parce qu'ils
connaissent et la blague vert dehors
rouge dedans
dit autrement c'est des gens qui sont
avant tout rouspéteur donc c'est
beaucoup plus vrai au niveau national
qu'au niveau local
l'élu local baer peut ne pas du tout
correspondre à ce que raconte l'élu
national vert et par une très forte mans
11 petter avant d'être
écologiste
donc il ya des sujets sur lesquels il va
être constructif
d'autres sur lesquels il va pas les pros
du tour et puis vous trouver des gens
qui sont très allants sur les mesures
qui sont des mesures environnementales
dehors le monde
écologique classique bon il ya le grand
débat sur la taxe carbone en france en
c'est un podium en route les plus
fervents les plus fervents partisans de
la taxe carbone se retrouve donc le
monde politique
il est
la représentation classique on en a à
gauche droite machin et ses rangs
n'a pas de
ne correspond pas à la réalité des
prises de position sur les problèmes
environnementaux de la représentation
nationale et c'est du reste un des
problèmes parce que les sols qui disent
qu'ils veulent incarner ce courant
ce sont des gens qui sont beaucoup plus
dans la protestation que dans la
construction
donc ce sujet est un sujet qui est
maltraitée en deux mots et en un mot
dans le débat politique mal logement
le vrai chiffre c'est que les sens
charles tout seul juste et sage c'est 20
% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
le parc automobile mondial 6%
les camions c'est 4% les chaudières de
bâtiment 7 6% à la charmante oui
transport aérien ces deux jours
20% en espagne on demande aux français
si vous pensez que ça contribue
significativement l'infraction des
français qui me disent oui c'est ça
campus
qui demandait aux français si le
nucléaire contribuer significativement
aux émissions de gaz à effet serre dans
le monde est la bonne réponse est de 50
% des français pensent que la reddition
alors que le maire peut avoir tous les
défauts qu'on veut un des défauts qui
n'a pas ses vues aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre puisque la réaction
nucléaire qui consiste à casser des
noyaux d'uranium en deux ne produit pas
de gaz carbonique pour produire du gaz
carbonique brûler du carbone les du
carbone c'est pas équivalent à agacé à
la question de savoir si le nucléaire
est dangereux
en fait c'est pas la question de la
question c'est est-ce que c'est plus ou
moins dangereux que le reste par le
doute et l'énergie produite énergie
nucléaire quand on regarde de près on
fait que celle qui présente le moins
d'inconvénients par kilowattheure
produit une fois je vous ai dit ça je
vais pas vous dire faut s'en séparer
je vais vous dire surtout de la garder
et en fait il ya plein de pays où il
faudrait l'augmenter
parce que c'est le moyen de se
débarrasser au plus vite les centrales à
charbon est né dans une course contre la
montre avec le changement climatique
la totalité des centrales à charbon ou à
disparaître de la surface de la terre
ici à 2050
ici est ce que tu te sens ont recours au
nucléaire n'a aucune chance d'y arriver
sans le recours au nucléaire on n'a
aucune chance d'obtenir les 2 degrés on
sent leur contenu clair on n'a aucune
chance de vivre
donc je pense qu'il faut surtout face à
séparer et qu'au contraire il faut le
grand ce pagne qui vont faire n'importe
quoi donc à dire qu'il faut se livrer à
n'importe quelle expérience tube il si
ça n'avait dépendu que deux mois au type
de réacteur qu'on a construit à
tchernobyl
j'aurais jamais autorisé sa construction
il reste quand la lituanie est rentré en
europe elle avait un réacteur du même
type et laurent pas dire on veut bien
jouer dans l'europe mais vous mettez ce
réacteur alors et n'auront pas eu raison
c'est pas parce que je suis pour le
nucléaire qu'il faut faire n'importe
quoi mais dire aujourd'hui messes
nucléaire de côté serait une énorme
erreur
si on veut préserver la paix les
écosystèmes
alors dechy project
sion également si ça que j'ai créée en
2010 et si je la fais très courte
l'idée est d'essayer de faire le lobby
des grandes entreprises qui sont pour la
décarbonation de l'économie alors
pourquoi est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
ça parce que même si j'ai pas fait
sciences po j'ai lu tomlin
quand j'étais plus jeune et cool mais du
coup je vraiment rapproché sein de ce
que j'avais déjà observé j'ai trouvé que
c'était un des points les plus
extraordinaires
et tocqueville dans son analyse du
fonctionnement de la démocratie explique
qu'en démocratie si je suis un peu
taquin l'élu est un exécuteur
testamentaire
dit autrement il a une marge de
manoeuvre propre qui très faible sauf en
période de crise donc en fait c'est
quand les pays traverse la guerre en
restant des démocraties que les élus se
mettent à avoir des pouvoirs extrêmement
fort sinon c'est des exécuteurs
testamentaires
en fait ils freinent le sondage de la
veille ça vous voulez moi je vais faire
ça
et l'élu une perception de ce que veut
la société soit au travers un mode très
large et très imparfait qui s'appelle
d'espionnage soit au travers de mode
plus extensifs détailler les moins
parfait qui sont les corps constitués
les camps sainte hermine et donc l'élu
il va prendre la température de la
société en discutant avec des syndicats
de patrons des syndicats de salariés les
représentants du monde enseignant déjà
cas d'éric en direct des économistes et
c'est ce qu'on appelle des corps
intermédiaires dont vous ferez partie si
tout se passe bien dans votre vie future
de chine projette à la vocation de
fournir un discours un peu détaillé
donc ça peut pas conserver en public
parce que le grand public nous parce que
par les médias et les médias c'est
terriblement électeurs les médias ça
fait déjà 25 novembre
les médias seront donc le gie project
peut pas s'adresser à la population dans
son ensemble s'est passé par les médias
on va fournir un disque au complexe ne
s'adresse pas aux élus en direct parce
que ça ne sert à rien tant qu'on ne
représentait pas un groupe de pression
donc le gie projet que s'adresser aux
corps intermédiaires
monde économique en dix ans travaillons
ensemble un truc qui est de votre
intérêt ça veut pas dire que tout
l'économie qui intéresse sérieusement on
en avait discuté avec ce don sénateurs
alors si je dis de qui s intérêts de
décarbonés l'économie et bien c'est
l'intérêt dans le lien avec ce que vient
de dire juste avant des gens qui sont
des centrales nucléaires des barrages au
les éoliennes c'est l'intérêt des gens
qui font avancer des trains et des cas
et versus la voiture c'est l'intérêt des
gens qui ont besoin du monde automobile
font des petites voitures ont par des
grosses c'est l'intérêt des gens qui
sont capables d'isoler des bâtiments
c'est l'intérêt des gens qui sont
capables de proposer de nouveaux
services qui mutualisent les objets déjà
existants qu'il s'agisse de richert
blaquart ou airbnb c'est l'intérêt des
gens qui vont favoriser l'alimentation
de proximité pas trop riches en boeufs
c'est peut être par exemple l'intérêt
d'une chaîne de distribution qui est
spécialisée dans les petits magasins
approvisionnement local
donc en gros notre internaute cherche à
faire mousser l'intérêt de faire grimper
aux arbres moi donc ce qu'on cherche
c'est d'aller chercher un par un des
gens qui ont un intérêt objectif parce
qu'on durcisse la contrainte sur
les combustibles fossiles afin de
constituer un lobby qui va peser sur la
décision
c'est exactement ça c'est un oubli je
vous assure
et l'argent est saine grand cerf
réfléchir à des propositions qu'on peut
faire pour décarbonés l'économie par
exemple on a travaillé sur le prix du
carbone et la proposition de corridors
de prix qui a été porté par ségolène
royal viennent chez nous
on l'a travaillé sur la reconversion de
l'économie vers plus d'investissements
et moins de consommation une partie du
plan du nkr dans l'efficacité
énergétique chez le parti voilà l'idée
c'est d'infuser le monde économique avec
des propositions qui vont avoir la
possibilité d'être reprises et de gagner
en audience
appuyé par des gens qui ont intérêt donc
il en garde moi je et je veux vraiment
à dix ans après il m'a pris le délire
complètement mégalo que je n'ai jamais
réussi à concrétiser de faire non pas
terminator les climats 14 avec dicaprio
et marion cotillard c'est à dire un film
qui aurait eu deux caractéristiques être
porté par des gens suffisamment connue
pour être sûr qu'ils seraient vus avec
une intrigue dont j'étais sûr qu'elle
marche aurait alors une très bonne
manière de faire ça c'est d'aller aux
états unis toutes les séries médicales
policière que vous avez aux états unis
grey's anatomy
etc sont des séries qui sont faites en
séparant les rides et les jambes c'est à
dire que vous avez des scénaristes qui
sont chargés du tout mauvais du traître
du méchant de la personne qui va mourir
une maman darroussin et à côté de ça
vous avez des experts techniques qui
sont chargés de vérifier que sur la
partie strictement technique de la série
par exemple et terme qu'on utilise quand
on opère les gens dans grey's anatomy
le simulateur afin de
le truc qui vous mesurer le rythme
cardiaque et c'est le fait quand on
prononce telmo de maladie c'est bien tel
truc qui s'affiche sur l'appareil de
monitoring brise ce genre de truc qui
est strictement rien qui prête le flanc
à la critique
alors moi j'avais exactement la bonne
idée sur un film une série tiers de
faire un truc à grand spectacle avec le
très trop longs échanges
ce que vous pouvez la route à un mec sur
la partie strictement scientifique et au
changement climatique
il n'y a rien à redire et donc j'ai une
caisse de résonance médiatique unique
qui soit le corpus scientifique sur
cette question le disais c'est tout les
scientifiques de la planète 10 sur la
partie climat ce truc là c'est nickel
s'est d'ailleurs pourquoi nous lui je
suis sûr que ça aurait été un
blockbuster
j'étais en parler de la société sont
absolument pas pris donc
m
j'aurais essayé durable si j'ai
l'occasion de la rate un je pense que je
réussirai je suis donc ça répond à vos
questions je suis persuadé que ça ne
fait partie des secteurs extrêmement
puissant de diffusion de la politique
c'est beaucoup jean marc jancovici
préconçues